now I started this off saying oh I want
these shapes to be a bit unusual right
maybe you were hearing me explaining
this and thinking that shape doesn't
look very unusual at all it's got heaps
of straight edges there are lots of
specific things you need to know about
so I want you to belong or underneath
this draw another diagram for me but I
wanted to look like this
okay now the to the straight lines yeah
yeah now this is looking decidedly
weirder than this guy do you agree it's
like oh you know this is like a nice
name like you cut this out or something
but this it's like yeah both of these
sides a wonky this could be like a
riverbed or something like that
okay now the thing is once you have this
rough idea of how to do this you can use
this idea on this just by slicing it
across the middle watch if I put a
straight line down the middle imagine
that's you and your friends walking
across right and then you make some
measurements I can play exactly the same
game as I did with that I'm just gonna
do it twice watch do you see what I've
got I've just got two of them jam
together does it does that make sense
like ones on the top this is H this is H
here is the first distance here is the
middle one and then here is the last one
right so you can work out the top bit
you just go ahead you country numbers
and you'll get that and then you replay
all over again but you've got this as
your first distance and then this as
your middle distance and then this as
your last distance that are all
different but if I add them a lot
aha bottom part there's my estimate
yeah yeah and you'll often find the
diagram they give you actually slices it
for you and then you have you know
there's a top part and a bottom part
well for example these two happen to
look pretty equal to each other
by coincidence so that's fine I would
just go ahead I've used this formula all
over again and sure some numbers might
repeat no big deal yeah I expect I would
get something slightly different off of
these but that's okay the approximation
takes care of now you remember I said -
it's an approximation okay there's one
more trick we have about sleeve if we're
like I'm not content maybe I need like
more accuracy or something like that
what would you do is come back to this
original diagram did yours should look
like mine except without the red lines
is that what yours looks like yeah now
what would you imagine doing I'm
actually gonna do it you're gonna have
it is to take this off and get rid of it
so now I've got this now what I've got
now is like the original shape but if I
want to I can define a knob like this
okay my H is gonna be different do you
see that my edge is gonna be this far
like that okay but the smaller and
smaller I go the more accuracy I'll get
just like if you use like a ruler which
is more and more fine you're going to
get more and more detail of this shape
okay and in fact I could divide it up as
many times I want I can divide it like
this I can divide these guys up even
further until I get to a level of detail
that I'm happy with
okay so you'll see both of these you'll
see them saying hey can you do Susan's
room and do it two sided or they'll say
hey can you do since they're all but can
you go into more detail for me and you
just use this more and more times as is
necessary now the formula is hard to
remember every one I should point out to
you and extension one extension to
students they use this formula to and
they also
trouble memorizing it okay that's what
the reasons why it's um you'll find it
on the second page approximation using
Simpsons rules the formula is there
exactly as I've written it I will point
out back in my day we didn't have a
formula done tremendously so the way the
trick that I use and this is motley sees
that because you don't want to have to
refer to the formulation if you can
remember something right I looked at
this in the way we remember is that is
another rule that's very similar to this
and it's got different numbers
I always remember it's up its Simpsons
rule right it's since Israel who is the
most famous citizen it's her mom it's
her mom right and how many children does
he have again he has three right three
okay so we use that as our like little
mental cue to um remember what the right
numbers are this is always a bit tricky
but if you are ever in doubt go to your
machine it's there for this exact reason
all right so um what I want you to do is
if you haven't already you can drag
these down when you have a look at say
number one just have a look at number
one one eight you can see the numbers
there okay can you look at one a tell me
what are the h's we should we should
fees alone understand which number is
the H no month
you can't believe the H has to be thirty
because it's the one that's uncommon all
the way along okay so you can see it's
gonna be thirty in that case that tells
you that that eighteen the 16 and the 23
one of a what are they feeding you the
distance in eighteen sixty 23 perfect
okay